so now what does James Madison say is
the most important thing about the
Constitution and the chief way it will
protect our liberties he says it makes
ambition counteract ambition
in order as I see ideas written that's
very good how does it do that
that's what I'm asking then he says he
puts reason instead of passion that's
true and very important and how does it
do that what feature of the Constitution
best achieves these things is this one
of the obvious answers like separation
of powers yeah which he says is the
structure of the Constitution function
in other words there's no one provision
it's the whole thing
the structure is where because it will
channel the way we do politics to make
that way the results healthier the whole
structure right and the structure is
separation of powers that's how its laid
out and when he when he gets ready to
justify that that's where he talks about
the order of the human soul which has to
do with the arrangement of rationality
and passions it's worth adding that
Madison didn't think and the great
philosophers don't think that passions
are to be banished what you want is
terribly important and it's terribly
important that you want the right thing
and every choice you make is a
combination of thinking and desiring and
if you practice making choice as well
you will come not only to think better
about how to get the right thing but you
will want the right thing and so the
Constitution and its structure is
devised to engender the correct
cooperation between reason and passion
and that in your own lives you need to
do that very much need to do that a
little short lecture there are two kinds
of virtue
the greatest book in my opinion ever
written about ethics the first book
Aristotle's ethics and that he says in
there that there's two kind of virtues
doing virtues and thinking virtues and
that doing virtues have to do with what
you want the doing virtues are three the
prime ones their courage and moderation
and justice will take courage and
moderation courage has to do with pain
and moderation has to do with pleasure
and the virtue is the right disposition
toward those things you have to want to
do the brave thing if you want to do
what Aristotle says is the beautiful
thing the action that is beautiful to
behold if you want to do that than
you're courageous but if you do it like
charge the enemy when there's no hope
and no advantage to it then you're a
fool
you're imprudent and it's not really a
beautiful act then it means that it
takes thinking - if - you have to be
able to figure out what to do pleasure
is the same way to attempt to forego all
pleasure would be foolishness you'd be
giving up friendship you starve yourself
to death or something right but we're
talking about here about a structure the
channel's the public control of the
government in a way that encourages good
character in the people